guess who's coming to Austin tomorrow
what am i doing you're gonna this is
accidental you showing up in Austin this
weekend
you have come to Austin Texas on a good
night because I've lined something up
for this evening that will have us
literally this is Joe what was that
their sex show you're gonna do that in
front of hundreds of people yeah you
gotta let them know they can't have this
because people always want what they
can't have
so made a lot of progress these past six
months you weren't gonna call her you
weren't up in a texture you are not here
do you understand me close the window
home she's moving on Stan you should go
and do the same thing this isn't College
anymore I cannot see him tonight I'm not
ready you got a short window buddy you
need to lay some track came all the way
to Austin just
f creeping param antic the old stab
there's a shame that you flew all the
way to Texas to stock the girl's
underwear to start come here to stop
okay can you see me even is this I see
you've taken up photography what did you
think
Oh
that's a hairy Python Python that's it
this is good this is good
that was your head I think no I've got
her